we're gonna jump to this story maybe uh
uh maybe the last story before we go to
super chats
ladies and gentlemen we made the news
in Trump's trial a secret fight over a
juror's right-wing news source I love
this because this proves to all of you
it's a cult
check it out
they say
e Gene Carroll's lawyers tried to
exclude the man who listened to podcasts
by the provocateur Tim Poole he remained
on the jury that found the ex-president
libel provocateur is a great word
provocateur I like that what what do I
do they call Milo yiannopoulos a
provocateur well he goes out he gives
speeches do I do do I ever leave this
building do I make phone calls to
anybody do I contact members of Congress
or do I just sit here and have
conversations with people the beauty is
very provocative it is I have to say and
evocative
take a look at this the juror was a 31
year old man who said he lived in the
Bronx for all his life during jury
selection he he said uh that he tended
to avoid news but listen to Independent
podcasts every now and then and listen
listed one example
the original transcript inaccurately
captured the podcast title as Temple but
lawyers from his Carol the writer who
filed the lawsuit according to uh
accusing Mr Trump of rape later learned
through news reports that the anonymous
juror identified only as 077 had
actually said he listens to Tim Poole
here's the best part you guys ready for
this Mr pool's YouTube channel includes
dozens of recordings that push
hard-right views his podcast which has
been criticized as a vector for
conspiracy theories is called the
culture War well hold on there a minute
the culture war is a new show that has
been hasn't been accused of anything
it's never been in the news it's only
been around for about two months 11
episodes that's fake news and I I wonder
if that's actually defamatory in that
you could argue things about timcast IRL
the show y'all are watching now because
it's been around for years and has been
in the news several times but the
culture War hasn't been no the culture
War podcast hasn't been covered by
anyone and I'm surprised they even found
it you know what they did they searched
for Tim pool podcast and found the
culture War podcast with Tim Poole which
is a new show which has very little
viewership relative to this show or even
Tim cast news it's a vector a vector
that's why they said dozens of
recordings like IRL has a bit more than
dozens yeah I think IRL has like 2 000
or something like that and then the
culture War has like 25 and the morning
videos that you do I mean you put out a
dozen morning videos five videos a day
right on timcast news and there's like 3
000 videos also they don't even mention
that you like worked for vice like
you're such a lefty and so many other
issues they're like this far right guy
yeah you you would imagine New York
Times would do a little bit more
research and have figured that out I
know you wouldn't
it says during the confidential
questioning jira 77 said that Mr pool
quote is like middle adding that the
podcaster gets different political
figures or just celebrities like that on
the left on the right during and also
describe the podcast as balanced do you
know why yeah he watched this show
probably because we had like a
run-of-the-mill celebrity on the show
one time right this is a guy who
apparently said that he only He's only
seen a few episodes and it may be
because we've had musicians we've had
people like Ethan simply subtly on the
show an actor and we just we just talked
about you know moderate political issues
we have had people who are totally
apolitical who struggle to even talk
with it's scientists doctors
but they don't know anything about it
this is the first show that I've ever
watched of yours yeah so the one you're
on yeah the one I'm on here you go
welcome he said that he'd been doing
doubles at work and listen listen to Mr
pool's show three or four times in the
past six months said he never had heard
of Miss Carol and was confident he could
be fair to both sides here's a guy who
actually said Trump is liable for sexual
abuse not rape after almost 30 years
that's amazing and they're like that's a
fan of Tim pool who should be removed
from the jury here's what they said look
at this a lawyer from his Carol said
that the juror appeared to get his news
from a single really virulently
extremist podcast it's amazing but I can
sit here being like Trump is wrong about
the fraud narrative and I'm pro-choice
and they're a lot he's an extremist but
you see what they're trying to do
two things they they want to create a a
bifurcation between me and regular
people because they don't want regular
people to hear honest commentary from
honest people
and well I mean I I'll I'll leave it at
that that's that's basically it to
defame and to push people away so those
are the two things I guess so he wasn't
dismissed no and then he actually sided
with them
right and what's what's the story here
then I don't know why is it why isn't
curious why this is actually a story why
is it that they they ran that story
about the Allen Texas shooter yeah who
posted four clips of me and then in the
same week they're like a right-wing
extremist news source there's no news
here the guys say to listen to the show
three or four times and that was the end
of it they didn't dismiss him and then
he sided with them why is the New York
Times Politico The Daily Beast whoever
else they're all writing this up because
they're afraid of you yeah I mean I
think it's because you take their
audience and also you actually do have a
lot of moderate views unlike both
mainstream Fox News and all the
mainstream leveling Publications like
that's just how it is that's gotta be it
because there's no other reason to say
oh did you know there was a juror that
wasn't dismissed but he admitted that he
watched this show four times and people
are like three times who weren't aware
of you or IRL already have heard your
name probably because of the Allen Texas
stuff so New York Times jumping on this
bandwagon that I think they often look I
mean because it's not the first time
you've trended I think people want this
show to be something uh more extreme so
they can shun it they want you to have
every time they Google your name they
want far right extremist terrible person
to come up but it doesn't work it
doesn't work because you do this show
every night and prove them wrong they
definitely turned band camp off to you
well bandcamp spreading defamation or
something like that but there there
there's a cult they're extremists and
the people who watch this show probably
already agree with me when we say these
people are in a cult because you can
have a leftist like Lance from the surfs
on the show overtly say he's
pro-abortion at any time for any period
for any reason Matt binder left to say
the exact same thing sitting next to
Sheamus Coughlin a Catholic conservative
pro-lifer who wants abortion banned
outright and me saying well I think
there should be some restrictions but
maybe only after viability which is the
middle
and the person on the left says you're
all far right
like right if my opinion and and you
know is the average opinion based on
polling
then what are they talking about they're
just lying that's what they do they lie
and I'm I'm part of partly grateful
because this makes it easy to prove
they're lying that's it is there is
there anybody else that has as many
diverse people on their podcast as you
do I mean I mean there's certainly you
right well I like I think Patrick Bet
David uh has way more uh people across
because what they really want to do is
silence everybody not just you but the
silence everybody that you would ever
have on and make sure they can put those
people into a box right and because you
know CNN's never going to have those
people on Fox News won't have them on
either Fox News won't have people on who
they're afraid of are associated with
people even if that person has never
done it two layers deep yeah you'll be
like yeah you will you you went to this
one party with this guy you know like
whatever
I think this is actually Politico wrote
up an even bigger story saying there was
inferred bias or whatever Tim pull a
far-right pro-trump commentator who has
aligned himself with figures like Steve
Bannon what does he mean aligned himself
with people like Steve Bannon it means
you talked to him one time and you
didn't scream in his face but I we we on
the the show the members only show I we
argued about the fraud narrative and I
told him to his face he was wrong yeah
and I said Trump was unelected he was
anti-elected people voted against him
and we went in this long thing and he
was like well that's an interesting
point and I think he's been in the show
twice yeah what what is this you're not
allowed to platform it at all you're not
allowed to talk to people no no talking
to other people
most people dislike so make make those
associations and like we can then create
a box around these people who make
commentary with some sense exactly when
I think of you the first thing I think
of is not he's pro-trump
no most people don't yeah like now me
most I think it's fair if somebody says
that they think of me as pro-trump
because like all I did was make memes
about Trump
but but for them to call you the
pro-trump extremist is just hilarious it
it doesn't it doesn't fit at all they
debunking themselves especially when we
have like Lou gradkowski on this show
for like seven months at a time and
people say he has Trump derangement
syndrome or Ian Crossland who says some
of like the craziest leftist stuff half
the time and then rolls twenties the
other half like the the it's it's
you know look
for legal reasons I'll say this is
besmirching my good name and I am
concerned about reputational damage
which we'll be pursuing but part of me
is like okay dude make me more famous my
name's all over the Press now and people
are wondering what this is all about
yeah I love I love their New York Times
writing about the culture War great we
need to press because that you weren't
going to get in there with if it wasn't
bad press which all press is good for us
it's even bad press we'll see we'll see
I don't know and they always tell you
like you get into a car accident don't
say you're fine because you don't
actually know what injuries you might
have and there's so many stories where
someone gets like T-boned and then like
well I feel okay I think we're good and
then a year later like actually in that
accident you chip the bone and now you
need like a ten thousand dollar surgery
or a hundred thousand dollar surgery so
it's like you know we'll see we'll see
maybe you know but uh we sponsor
ourselves we're building our own
companies we we are member supported I'm
not worried about companies dropping us
in terms of sponsorships
I'm not I'm not worried about it at all
and now with Twitter Rumble competing
with YouTube I'm not worried about
YouTube either there's nothing they can
do they've lost the the the the things
they've said like when Keith olberman's
tweeting at me and like this this Alan
Texas thing comes up I'm like literally
I don't care what these people think at
all there is no concern I have none we
have built infrastructure we are
building infrastructure Rumble is
building infrastructure Elon Musk is
building infrastructure what do we have
to be worried about at this point say
whatever stupid garbage fine we'll sue
you if it's defamatory and you'll lose
true and it has no impact did Keith come
out of retirement to attack you he
retired he's retiring for he's retired
like four times from Twitter thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time